[Music]
now they're not today hey
oh yep that's right um well for all you
californians around here
the uh masked mandate has been lifted i
feel like a spirit has been lifted
on the people of this state our saliva
is no longer infectious
i don't know how i feel about it yeah
same yeah
you guys a little on the fence about
well i'm i'm still a super spreader i
haven't gotten vaccinated
oh really you still ha i didn't realize
that well you haven't been vaccinated
yeah i don't believe in it
my
[Applause]
no no but um i got the vid and then
proceeded to give it to some other
people
and uh yeah and we got that natural vex
no no that isn't
like uh i know it's totally different it
is yeah yeah sure if you haven't been
vaccinated you should still
definitely come back are you sure they
say yeah there's a lot of evidence for
it yeah
it your immunity goes down i gotta do
more research on that but
but yeah since you know not everyone can
get vaccinated they ask that since
you know we have this free range
immunity we wait to get vaccinated so
that's what i've been doing
and uh i got like a week left and then i
can go
really how long is the they say free
range
yeah yeah they say if you get it you
should wait like three
how long did they tell you that you're
allowed to walk around on the street for
before you have to go see someone from
the government
oh in california is that a california
joke
no it's just like a comment a funny
comment on
no um jake's in the studio today yeah
he's not like
you know gotta have egypt
that's another thing there's no phone
phones there's no masks we're waiting
for the no pants man
yeah we are bone free boys right now
excuse me
[Laughter]
up uh so when sam comes there's gonna be
no skin
no skin the skin lord is gonna come back
we're gonna be all muscle so it's really
hot in l.a this week is it how what
temperature is it in texas right now
um it's definitely there's been a heat
spike
all over oh wait yeah no i saw that i
saw that apparently like some of the
power
systems are failing due to heat now
whereas like literally like four months
ago they were failing due to cold
yeah it's uh it was in the 90s which
honestly is not too
bad that's pretty normal for texas
summer
a hundred is considered not that bad
yeah but texas has the humidity and
that's what makes it worse
yes it does i mean i've gotten used to
it you know minnesota was
was no different uh in the summers i
mean it was a little cooler there but
it's still
95 and humid uh
you know pretty somewhat regularly it
was that way back in nam
[Laughter]
i mean yeah that's the thing about heat
is that like it dissipates
alright unless there's a lot of water in
the air aka humidity and then it just
like it traps that heat
yeah what is vietnam like climate wise
it's a lot like louisiana and texas it's
just like it's just hot and humid
okay yeah half the year it's raining the
other half it's rain sometimes we should
get red like one of those like
veterans hats like less specific and it
just says like vietnam
it just says vietnam i was like nab what
year were you there oh seven something
like yeah before that oh five to seven
yeah and then another
six years after that i would go back
like twice a year for a month
each good times i love vietnam it's
amazing
yeah that time you got to go there and
we got some really cool shots of you
riding around on those mopeds that's
right
yeah that was really fun that was fun
just to watch for me to watch you do it
yeah vietnam's crazy because you have
all these like freaking motorbikes
and it's different over the last it's
different lately more recently uh like
you know
10 15 years ago it was much more of a
thing there were fewer cars there
everyone rode motorbikes
and there were no traffic laws they were
just
rivers of motorcycles the only way to
cross the street
was to literally just look at the other
side of the street and just start
walking at a very slow and consistent
speed
without stopping without looking you can
close your eyes and do it
and all of the motorbikes would just go
around you oh the moment you started
being inconsistent is the moment you got
hit
what you did have to keep an eye out for
a bus because the buses don't stop
they were just running over watch out
for them buses they don't stop
yeah i'm sure that's a lot different now
there's a lot more cars there it's a lot
more developed now a lot more
rules yeah but that's um i went to
the only time i had to bribe a customs
worker to get out of the country
whoa what did you buy them with
money how much it was much okay so like
this is actually a legitimately real
story when you enter the country when
you're just visiting they give you this
card and you have to keep the card in
order to leave the country and i forget
it doesn't make much sense i think you
have to do some specific things if you
lose the card
anyway i totally forgot that i lost it
and i get up to the customs agent to
like get me into the terminal
and he's like where do you have i was
like i don't have the card i don't know
and he's like
it gets really frustrating kind of like
he leans on he's like
you have money like i'm not getting
exactly like that i was like
okay i pull out my wallet the only money
i had was a 20 u.s bill
and i was like is this okay and he's
like he grabs it kind of like
puts in his things and like looks around
nice nice and i was like did i literally
just bribe
a government worker yeah you did you do
well that's an m for you
yeah it's very corrupt yeah
understandably so they've had a
tumultuous history
yeah yeah but very good french coffees
as well really if you're into that sort
of thing yeah you know about that
well i mean it's france was in there for
a while was that oh
tremendous amount of french heritage oh
cool they brought all their cafes with
them
oh yes and now they've and then
obviously the vietnamese did their own
little twists on it so
right right yeah cool that's kind of
cool yeah
how do we get to talking about vietnam
oh yeah humidity yeah
yeah it's been really hot in l.a this
week and that is why we're all wearing
shorts that's what got us on this whole
uh
topic hey chase is in vegas right now
and it's like
110 there today and it'll be up in 118 i
think i saw
like on thursday yeah it's tuesday but
it's just gonna keep
going up that's that's anything
why do people live there i have a good
question it's a dry heat
i mean even even with a dry heel burn
your skin right off the bat
there's a threshold like you know
phoenix arizona can get that hot
las vegas palm springs can get that hot
i was in palm springs last summer
when it hit 120. and i honestly i think
anything above 110 115 is just like a
threshold of heat has been met where
it's like
legitimately oppressing to be outside
when i
when i graduated from the bar or just
when i took the bar exam and finished
law school i i went out to see rhett who
was living in
uh phoenix oh yeah and uh when i drove
out there
and i got there it was 115. um
and uh it you know it was like 90 at
night
so it was and we were in scottsdale so
it was
it was like it was hot but that's i mean
ninety-eight
day that's no it's yeah it's that hot
because it's it it literally is i mean
it's so dry
it's it's like feels like an oven yeah
but anyways did you have to like i had
to literally let out the
the air out of my tires a little bit
because the temperature had increased
the pressure
and that they were like way too high
pressure i had to let out the air i
didn't know enough about cars to know
that
okay when i went there at that time
that's why people live there
less air usage yeah it's less to fill
your tire yeah you cracked it
yeah it's cheaper because i get you you
send all the mouth breathers there
all right but anyways enough about the
gosh dang weather um
are you guys working on this starting
off this podcast talking about the web
hey guys welcome to the corridor cast
where it's hot it's always hospital it's
only gonna get hotter
it will i'm writing a new video we can
talk about that in a bit but i'm more
intrigued to hear about this
james bond yeah matt and nick and i have
been on a james bond quest
this week seeking to explain to
the world really uh
how do you as a person new to the james
bond universe
like me yeah how do you not really how
do you watch
a simple video you know and in like five
minutes understand
the basics of what you're getting into
you know who is james bond is it a
single guy is it
is it an alias for the job it's like six
dudes
it's like six different ones right yeah
of varying ages
right like totally varying age oh yeah
yeah there's no consistency
so to someone new to james bond it's
like well what's the timeline here
like how does this how does this make
sense so the reality of it is that
there isn't a timeline that's the
reality is they started writing them in
the 60s
you know or ian fleming wrote the
original book and then they started
shooting the films in the 60s
and there's kind of a like there's
specter which is like this evil
organization
that the connery films sort of center
around but then after that it kind of
gets expanded from there
and there's not really like a
clear and concise cinematic universe
like
people are used to today yeah you know
it's all about the cinematic universe
youngsters love how does this logic tie
into the five
that i saw before that you know and that
star wars is
people are obsessed with making sense of
the star wars universe
so you're telling me that maybe the
movies and the way they tried to make
the cinematic universe is a little messy
and need some clarification and some
cleanup exactly
we need a through line in the james bond
series and there's a way to do it
needs the world of the james bond series
needs a third line
and we can do it we believe we can do it
i'm saying like
the world the
[Laughter]
we've got venn diagrams we've got
point-to-point charts
we've got matrices we've got charlie day
over in the corner
yeah oh yeah it's just spazzing out so
we've been digging through the archives
um we've boiled it down there's two
technically two films that were non
i don't know if it's eon or eon
production
it's a production company that's
produced all the james bond films
it's either called eon or eon
productions
and this company has done all but two
technically one of them was like a spoof
comedy so i don't think we're gonna
really
focus on that one and that doesn't exist
the second one
is a sean connery return
after he technically oh is this the
the secret movie well it's called never
say never again
and it was released in 1983 which was
like 10 years after
he stopped doing them okay yeah
nevermind i was thinking
i i feel like there's a bit of a
surprise movie that we're going to throw
in that
i don't think we should talk about there
will be a couple of surprises
yeah we're not going to tell people yeah
there's some stuff we're playing with
but i think the basic through line of
this series is that
well if one when one bond
one actor bond dies quote unquote or
or rather when the next movie
transitions to a new actor
uh that old james bond is still in the
universe
so basically our our thinking is he's
got to die somehow right
there's no way there's no way around it
that bond has to die
he has to be reincarnated through
various means uh into a new
james bond watch out where you're
deciding that like james bond in
addition to the code name 007 was just
an uh a code name imagine this
essentially every
first tier navy seal operator in the
united states military
is named jamesbond 007 but there's only
one of them
right there's not a team it's not seal
team six there's only one guy
right and so every time that guy dies
the guy that comes up to replace him
right
also his name james bond double 07. do
you guys ever watch doctor who
doctor who has a similar type deal where
they deal with like you know they have
this character
and he's you know the show is going on
forever they gotta replace the actor at
some point
and they built it into the show that
like when the character like
quote-unquote dies
he regenerates into a new body he
doesn't die he just like oh it's
something happened i have to regenerate
and it's a
easy plot mechanism to add a new
character
so yeah we're basically just turning
james bond actors contracts ending
into them dying yeah to make this
emphatic universe
speaking of con there was a contract
controversy
around the um so in the connery films
there's this evil organization called
spectre if you haven't seen bond they
did a
more recent one with daniel craig called
spectre
the reason why they didn't touch it
in between when connery stopped and when
daniel crick when they did it with
daniel craig is because of a contract
dispute that went on for that long
wait what yeah yeah and so they couldn't
use the the
the head henchman or not the henchman
the head bad guy
jaws no everyone knows jaws
we have to include this guy as a kid
i wasn't to be completely honest i was
never really that into james bond but i
always remember
the jaws character with the metal teeth
yeah it's an iconic bat
it's iconic absolutely iconic same with
odd job actually we should probably put
him in there
yeah anyway so they had this dispute
they couldn't use even the name of the
bad guy who ran the organization
um until the daniel craig won and then
he comes back and then spectre comes
back
wasn't that javier bardem was that that
guy i believe it's like
blum something the actor who played him
i should say oh um
i don't know the bad guy's name is like
blum
man people are going to slaughter me in
the bottom of the universe for not
knowing this bad guy's name but it's
it's
something german blom beach wasn't it
played by that
glorious bastards villain uh getting
that wrong too i think it might be
i forgot oh that guy yeah yeah yeah uh
hans lieberman
he also plays the he also plays across
christopher
from uh jamie foxx and django unchained
oh hey there uh you just caught me
reading my
hero's journal courtesy of today's
sponsor the heroes journal
it's not a book so stop right there i'm
not even reading a book
i'm actually writing in it because this
journal is
a phenomenal little tool to help you
establish
goals for yourself and then how to seek
out the adventure
in everyday life to achieve those goals
throughout human history we've told each
other stories about
heroes what those heroes go through what
they're faced with and what they have to
do to adapt and survive
to accomplish the things that they are
seeking so if you're into fantasy
if you're into goal setting and you're
into coming up with a formulaic way
to set goals and achieve them for
yourselves this book
helps you do that this journal asks you
questions
that you should be asking yourself if
you are attempting to seek goals for
yourself
such as what is your call to action
what's the worst possible thing that can
happen to you if you refuse to seek
out what you want in life it asks you
those questions those are fundamental
questions that
a lot of people miss and this book has a
bunch of tools including daily sheets
that will help you
get day to day week to week month to
month to those goals
that you are seeking if you're just into
really cool visual art
this book is chalk all of it every page
has a new quote a new
sweet drawing a new evolution of design
and it's a really great tool and i'm
super happy to tell you about them so if
you guys are interested
click the link in the description below
and use the discount code corridor
cast to get 10 off your purchase huge
thanks to the heroes journal
for sponsoring be inspired gosh dang it
don't be sitting here watching this
podcast if you don't have goals for
yourself that's rule number uno
set them goals and then more importantly
wake up each day and do something
to you know to get there yeah
yeah yeah yep yep great actor yeah yeah
yeah
great guy so that's what so that
happened battle angel um and then
because of that
they had sort of like a universe that
they were building but then they had to
like
diversify away from that because that
for some reason i don't know what
happened but
they couldn't use it um and so then
that's when the universe got even more
messy
um yeah wasn't like sean connery off and
on like in a couple of movies where it
was like roger moore than it well that's
what i'm saying
about that non-productions one i didn't
know that john connery went up until
like 73 i want to say and then roger
moore took over
but then countering came back
and there's been a few of those like
overlapping things so didn't sean
connery pass away
yeah i think last year okay
so in our chronological universe because
if this is
the way that we look at it is it's
chronological so each release
date of the film you know we have to
take that at face value enough to say
well if that guy was james bond on that
day
then how do we explain this it's very
complex
we're taking some uh artistic liberties
yeah i think the rich has forgetting
whole films
yeah yeah yeah the real fun here is
going to be like how creative we can get
the bond
the bonds to die um and we got some
ideas for that so i should
should we just call this video
previously on james bond
james i mean i'm just saying
yeah we could instead of james bond but
he dies
yeah i don't know the the problem with
where we're currently at
and we're right in the middle of this
we've been working on this since monday
um
is tuesday is that the
we have all these death scenes right to
like explain okay who's james bond who's
james bond
who but after you do a few of those
you know the steam kind of runs out on
the joke so how do you
you can only really land the joke once
and then you need to reiterate on it and
evolve it so like that's like how you
how do you do that
and then it's also a matter of like we
we just gotta freaking watch the movies
because
there's so much i watched the first one
last night i'm gonna try actually going
through all of them the original first
one yeah
aren't there like 23 of them or
something like that i think there's 26.
you don't have to watch the non-eon
production i'm probably not going to
if i can make it through sean connery's
first yeah like that first chunk it's
like six films
i remember those ancient snowmobiles
they had
ain't just ancient snowmobiles yeah like
i believe they're scariest fossils
like snowmobile fossils that's a
terrible chariots but they have skis
yeah i am serious hey did
they scary chariots
indigenous like you know ice people
whatever that means i want to know yeah
can we look that up
i mean i mean sled's been around for a
very long time
yeah i guess a dog
isn't really gonna have a good day
it's not a chariot though because it
it's it's facing
it's the the opening is forward that
horse seems like it's having a good time
yeah and i guess the chariot
specifically refers to the type of
wheels on it too and like the
like the big wheels in the front type
deal right
yeah chairs had two wheels yeah yeah and
then you could you stepped on them from
the back
primarily battle weapons
i mean they're all just cars without
engines the end yeah
yeah meat cars yeah power about me
oh yeah all right so what have we
learned by going through all these uh
these uh bond oh boy i've learned i got
a couple things
well i've learned that the world has
changed a lot because uh
james bond is about one step away from
the caveman bonking the
the lady caveman on the head and
dragging her into the cave yeah
yeah he kind of so cancelled this there
is like seriously like some sexual
assault [ __ ]
in this yeah like sixties and seventies
ones oh yeah
wait are we on bond's side right now
because like he's telling
women they can't drive good and like all
this stuff that's like
really that was so common in those in
films back then yeah i'm like um
i was watching this one uh called uh
it's actually a really good movie
um but it's called uh a river with no
name
i think um it's got marilyn monroe in it
um and this cowboy actor and uh
wayne gretzky sorry no not wayne byrd
dr wayne
um but anyway there's this one scene
where uh
they're having this argument and um
she's trying to get away or something
and he like grabs her and like
brings like you know he grabs her and he
like pulls her onto the ground and
like is wrestling her and wrestles her
to the ground and then like starts
making out with her
and then it turns into and then she like
you know and then they make up because
of that
but it's very the little it's very
written by a dude obviously and it's you
know just that was
that was then yeah yeah and i think it's
uh
it's interesting to see a lot of that
stuff from the things that you were able
to get away with or do then
um not get away with it i guess yeah
yeah yeah i mean it was yeah it was how
it was depicted
in heart there's a there's like a weird
rating system with
uh the older films too where it's like i
think the
the one that i was looking at it was
rated like pg but it there's a scene
where bond like
rips a like a top off a girl and you can
clearly see
like her breasts
yeah they so they have like a yeah they
came to my law school and talked to us
about this one time
well they have a wait what film ratings
yeah please they have a com they have a
committee that like you know a small
group of people that
work for the mbaa and then the mp those
people get together
a group of civilians
just everyday civilians like a jury
basically just everyday people
yeah randomly and there's people that
you know say hey like i'm
i'd like to be a movie reviewer to for
the rating system and you can call me
when you need me and i'll come down
a lot of times people that live here in
l.a um and
it's just so they had somebody who was
one of those people and then somebody
from the mba
and they explained how this process
works and they just bring them down and
they don't tell you what the movie is or
what it's called or like who's in it or
anything they just put you in there and
they play it
and then after it's over they ask you
questions
what how did you how how would you feel
that movie would be rated
why you know and they and they try to
weed out the like
two extreme ends of the spectrum and go
with kind of what the common
like right yeah thought is on it and
that's how movies get raided
interesting wasn't there a documentary
about it yeah
there's like a whole documentary about
how uh the ratings were
a thing i forget who the tentpole movie
was within that movie it might have even
been like south park or something like
that
i don't know yeah south park's been
messing with ratings the rating system
forever yeah so uh the first james bond
movie
dr no was it doctor no yeah what year
did that come out
62 i think 1962 wow
yeah man literally like early like
almost
60 years ago yeah mm-hmm yeah so
think about that it's it's 60 years ago
it's it's not like
it's it's i don't think it's fair for us
to judge history by our standards today
um but it it is a it is insightful to
see
how things were done then yeah
absolutely
yeah it's more just like fascinating
it's very like very yeah and the way
that they shot the stuff
sometimes it's so janky i can talk about
that the technology was there at a
technology disadvantage
yeah well it's more than that because
actually it it kind of depended on the
bond too because
it seems like all of the the more stuff
um
was really slow paced in the action
and the sean connery like fist fighting
scenes were a lot faster pace
actually even though like a lot of the
time yeah it's usually just like a
camera shot wide maybe a couple of
close-up inserts
but for the most part it's like played
pretty like it's
in terms of the editing it was similarly
paced but it was just like the
the choreography of the fighting was so
slow and the more stuff
yeah and for some i guess like sean
connery just had like a little extra
like umph to his
performance and like allowed for a
little bit more
action but yeah it's interesting to see
the different bonds fighting style and
and how they utilize it roger moore was
50 years old when they shot
the final one that he was in yeah it's
so slow too like all the
if you go back and watch all the jaws
fight scenes there's first of all
there's no music
to it right so there's no score so it's
just like these slow
like drags just like hey like you know
hey i'm over here
let's wait 10 seconds for you to walk
over to me and then i'll punch you once
and then i'm going to step back for like
10 more seconds come back to me
it's like a three or four minute long
fight sequence that goes nowhere
needed less to be stimulated yeah i
guess
i guess so daniel craig is 53.
wow okay plastic surgery did not exist
back there
i mean that's legit
[Music]
was close to that when he stopped
playing it
yeah i mean he's i feel like daniel
craig's been in a lot more movies than
any other
bond as in as
many as sean connery he's really he's a
good actor i mean
he's quite probably he's maybe short by
one or two
definitely sean connery's original run i
think though
he's caught up his original run wow like
the first chunk
you know yeah but yeah man those movies
are crazy
the the lack of sound design too yes
like it's so simple
yeah that's really something that whole
shark sequence oh my god yeah that's
what i'm talking about
there's no sound and you're just
watching guys kind of swim underwater
and like i'd watch it twice before i was
like
okay now i know what's going on here
because like they're all dressed the
same
in like suits and you know diving suits
was there at least like music
or was it like yeah yeah there's some
music okay the flute
like the jazz flute that's about it but
imagine going to
um a theater today or getting a new
movie
um and watching it and going
you know i for the last five minutes i
i've just been totally confused about
what's going on
yeah yeah people are so
it does happen but not with the big
films
and not with the films that are con you
know considered
james bond it doesn't happen as often as
it
i think it did then just because you had
all these issues i mean think about
trying to film
a scene underwater with a with a film
camera
with what equipment can giant rails or
like a you know what did you eat did you
just say giant gills no giant rails oh
okay that's way less cool
you couldn't just you couldn't just jump
in there with a gopro
yeah yeah and have it filmed 4k
wow gopro man you know so
there's there's a lot of technical
disadvantages but still that that also
i mean that's that can't dictate how
you what you're gonna shoot you know you
have to say okay well this is my tool so
i need to make sure that my story
yeah and this tool works for it works
with this tool
um and i don't know if that was always
considered i mean yeah
the concept of like a moving camera had
only been around for like
a couple decades yeah but you know so
you know
right that's true you think about the
60s and you think oh
the the talkies the talking pictures
have only been around for what
35 years in 1960
so for us that would be as if talking
movies were invented in 1985
yeah that's so true yeah but i see i
totally see your point where it's like
especially for the action sequences you
can tell they were limited by technology
because
you know they they have to be like well
okay we want to film this stunt but how
do we cover it properly and properly
like have the audience understand what's
happening
in front of you because we don't have
action cams
we don't have anything where we can like
really get good shots of this stuff
yeah um from the sky like even like
helicopters and stuff were limited
back then to what what kind of coverage
they could get so it's like
normally what you see with action then
is like they're kind of wide they're
kind of locked off
and yeah you can see it you understand
what's happening but it's kind of boring
it kind of ends up being a little boring
for a lot of those men they try to speed
it up with the fast with the fast cut
yeah you know the fast cuts that just
doesn't work it doesn't confuses you
yeah yeah and everyone like always like
bends weird when they get
punched like
the one where the guy goes off the cliff
oh gosh yeah with the skis
they did a live stunt this guy's going
down a hill
it's james bond
off of a cliff skis on
pack uh sorry jump pack on
oh yeah yeah takes it and he's he's
going down
you can see the ground takes off his
skis
does something else like takes his
jacket off or something deploys
oh the parachute deploys a parachute in
a giant union jack
yeah yeah thing i've ever seen
in my life yeah that sounds crazy is
there something where like there's an
airplane chasing them or something like
that was the different one we looked at
okay because i remember looking at that
one i remember seeing that on a stuntman
reactor
yeah i think he like he jumps off a
cliff that's from one of the bras
i want to say or no it's a later one
yeah it's a pierce crossing one where he
jumps off this huge cliff
and then like gets in the sky dives in
no that's goldeneye
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh you should see
that if you're gonna see one
if you're gonna see something it's just
been a very long time you should see
golden eye it's it's a really good one
yeah i'm a casino royale type of guy oh
with 40 minutes of 40 minutes of ending
that didn't need to be in it
why does that movie go on for 40 minutes
after the plot's over the only thing i
remember from that movie is the epic
like i don't chase the beginning and
then all of like the the poker playing
that was
and he almost died of a heart attack the
opening sequence to that movie
is one of the parkour stuff yeah opening
sequence no no no you're talking
never mind you're talking the actual
yeah the very beginning of the wave yeah
that's right every
does that mean i just realized every
bond movie has
a very specially tailored uh opening
sequence does that mean our video needs
to have one too
i think it does i mean we're like
someone tries to say those or something
i kind of think that's a really good
idea obviously i think we got it we got
to have our own bond music yeah
yeah the recorder version recorder
just just like whistle the wolf whistle
animated silhouettes upon dying in
yeah we can we can think one up we could
do a quick
we could do a quick intro where um
somebody comes in with a file and they
go
and it's and it's m and m was like what
is it
he's like m mr bond
he's dead he puts down the file again no
yeah
not again and then she turns opens a
filing cabinet put it with another pulls
out the next name
yeah there's like a bunch of others that
are like x'd out yeah
already yeah that would help explain it
that's fun
yeah you do that as an as a little
opening
mm-hmm we should just sizzle have
opening and then you jump into the
they should have us all in like uh
tuxedos
yeah yeah fighting each other that'd be
fun
dude what if like while we're filming
this like every single person just has
to be wearing like a suit
at their desk just like at all times
that's a that's great did we just do 60s
friday where we all were
singles classy slim black ties i love it
i love that you should definitely do
that
i like that a lot one of the ways we
want to play with
bond uh dying or so to speak is to have
him be cancelled for sexual assault
yeah hey philip defranco if you're
watching uh maybe
maybe we could have you do a little
little cancellation segment
for the video i'd love to see the tweets
come in like
all the tweets yeah yeah bonds on
lunesto
like as part of the evolution of how he
dies like
it's just i think it's fun to throw in
jokes like that another one matt
you were talking about was um yeah
this is the smoking one yeah the smoking
one because he smokes all the time in
those early movies so
and there's actually a scene where i
think it's one of the villains are
revealed to be villains um goes like you
know you should really stop smoking it's
bad for you
and he has a little x-ray machine so we
can show
how his lungs are like messed up i think
he uses the x-ray to see a gun
in his coat jacket but instead it just
cuts to like the images on the side of
cigarette packages
yeah exactly yeah yeah they're just like
used cigarettes inside his lungs or
something
yeah stuff like that so i'm hoping we
can find
maybe like two or three more of those
yeah to sort of mix into the edit
because yeah that's the thing like i was
talking about earlier like it's the joke
it's stale pretty quick so we got to
figure out how to
build on it yeah people are literally
witnessing us brainstorm this video
before their own eyes yeah
yeah welcome to the brainstorm session
that's the quarter cast you're going to
get it all here
yeah you're going to get insights on how
we create videos you're going to get
the futurist podcast you're going to get
futurism or is it futurism or is it
futurology
um so wren on that note um you've been
down here
racking your brain today a lot of
reading
a lot of watching youtube videos and
then some thought outlining
yeah i mean so
every time what you're working on is it
an idea space this is how he starts
yeah alongside yeah well okay i'm i'm
re-tackling a video that i've already
re-tackled
uh it's it's like vfx artist reveals how
many solar
panels could power the world oh you are
doing that one i think so oh
i think it's time but i'm reminded about
why i gave up
on it the first two times which is why
because i didn't have what's his name
uh i mean it's it's complicated it's
it's
energy when people think of energy they
think of electricity but electricity is
only a
portion of the actual energy that we
generate and consume
a lot of that isn't electrified at all
transportation for instance a lot of
gasoline powering our cars
heating you know natural gas powering
our heaters and ovens and stoves and
stuff like that
um so when you see like these numbers
being
like thrown around like oh yeah we use
this much electricity it would take this
much to replace all that with solar
panels etc
it's like that is only just covering the
electricity that
and there's not really a clear number on
it's like i figured out okay so there's
tons of graphs i've read
a lot of graphs and whatnot and they all
cover like a breakdown of
of like you know the the sources
of of primary energy and uh sources of
electrical energy and all this stuff but
there's
there's a surprising lack of like
correlation between those two
and i mean there is i i hate kind of
talking about this stuff because people
start
trying to give suggestions to me here's
an idea and i i'm not really asking for
them
it's probably got an idea though i have
an idea yeah as a non-engineer
hold that thought as someone who's never
studied engineering
only law economics and youtube videos
let me give you a suggestion
on on what you could possibly do for the
gas thing
you take the number of gallons sold or
you know
sold um and then you multiply it by
or you and then you take the number of
miles driven
and then you figure out okay now i know
how much energy that is
well we know how much energy has been
generated
completely it's something on the order
of like
a couple hundred thousand terawatt hours
per year i think okay uh and that
includes all coil
coil wow natural gas uh uh gasoline
yeah coal was what i was saying not
coils and they're all they're out there
harvesting coils
yeah don't get the black lung when
you're harvesting them coils
because i was under the assumption for a
long time that electricity was a much
smaller component of the total energy
consumption
than it actually is but i was
i'd learned that the vast majority of
coal is just for electricity so that
actually increased the amount of energy
being
in the electricity component right and
originally i
i realized my previous outline that i
made actually is pretty good
uh so i'm probably gonna try to go with
that
yeah man no i've got a pretty good
outline for like where the video needs
to go
it's just a matter of like getting the
right numbers for what i'm trying to say
okay so is that is that why last time
you kind of
like went a different direction or you
did something else
is because you don't couldn't really get
the numbers in but the outline was good
i forget the specific reason
why i abandoned this idea last time it
was during the pandemic and i think i
was just struggling to write anything
yeah yeah it was i i only made like one
video last year
that was like a special you know like
that was a like a science communication
type special i did a few others but
you know i am really wanting to do
nerf drone 2.0 and i don't really want
to get many details on that but i'm
hoping to work with more people on it
and it's good basically it's going to be
bigger better and more dangerous
do you think jan has a fighting chance
we got to figure out how to incorporate
jan into this video he was what made
that
initial video work so well it was just
that story between us yeah
i i think i'll go on i think he should
you know i mean have you seen scream
yeah okay screen journal screaming i
know you did last summer
yeah but i know what you did last summer
came out because
of scream oh ryan was like wait no i
thought that was the tagline of scream
what was the tagline of scream no it was
ah just like i know what you did
the summer came out a year after school
okay yeah wasn't that like a parody
no no okay i don't know
scary movie was the parody one right
right so scream
has this scene where sydney
you know is at her house and it's the
afternoon
and uh which actor was that she was was
that
uh she's in the house of cards and um
nev campbell something
i believe is it nev campbell i thought
it was like
okay come on man come on i should watch
yeah who is you know all the actors
lead actor or the woman we're talking
like at the beginning of the movie right
when she's like hearing the phone calls
and the the scream dude's like
thanks jamie any thanks jamie
um so anyways we called jam
it's a sunny quiet peaceful afternoon
and jan is enjoying his
time and he gets a call and it's just
like
yeah and you and it's you on the phone
behind a voice interpolator you're like
jen
the drone is coming for you
and then you know it punches it on his
face we do the thing where you pull
you push in and you zoom out oh yeah you
know and then he's like
and he grabs his nerf gun and then
yeah there's a little teaser i can see
that i want to i'd like to
like incorporate him in the build
process somehow a little bit he's just
going to talk
crap about you which is i guess i guess
that's what he needs that's kind of the
process
yeah it kind of fuels you yeah
yeah we have to keep it we have to keep
him behind
an enclosure so that he doesn't meddle
with the design
i'll text him right now hey do you want
to come talk crap to ren he will be
he'll reply yeah the general idea of the
second drone is basically it's it's
bigger so it can hold a bigger nerf
nerf blaster uh ideally the have you
guys seen the new nerf guns with the new
nerf darts
they're like they're slightly shorter
and they've got like little wingtips on
the back
almost they're they're way more accurate
they're way faster and they're way
quieter
deadlier at jan's birthday party at
rockahoola there's a couple guys rocking
it and it was just like
not those like like prototypes they're
like black darts
no no no those are just straight up
airsoft with the phone yeah yeah guys
are dangerous
yeah we never like usually we had to ban
those by the way because they look like
real guns and they hurt
yeah that's not fun nerf that's just
paint why don't you just use those
milsim bullets that they use in military
training exercises
because it's got to be nerfed it's kind
of a nerve rocks
it's a bigger drone so we can fit either
a slightly bigger blaster
more payload or more ammunition but the
trick that i'm really hoping to nail
there's a couple youtubers i'm hoping to
work with
is head tracking aiming so you have the
goggles on
and there's a gimbal that has head
tracking with the gun attached to it
and the fpv camera attached to it or
maybe it'll be a two-stage thing there's
two cameras one person doing the aiming
one person doing the flying
i don't know yet that's yet to be
decided that sounds like maybe that's
like a
third version maybe the second version
is just bigger
bad or better or bigger no jake because
the
easy version yeah that's really well
it's not going to be easy to build a
giant drone that shoots nerf darts right
well because i don't know it's
because the the the build i did last
year can scale up i can literally do the
exact same thing
and it's bigger but there's not really
any sort of novel change it's just like
okay
and it'll probably get views but it
probably won't be as good as the first
video i i like i really want to have
some sort of novel difference
and i think having like a head tracking
aiming system
would be really sweet that would be
sweet it was already so
op run
yeah uh get the help of someone who
knows how to do programming
and they program what exactly the head
tracking what does that mean okay so
basically there's this
thing called an imu it's an inertial
measurement unit and contains three
sensors in it a gyro a magnetometer or
magnetometer
and an accelerometer basically it's able
to detect any sort of orientation change
pretty accurately all of our phones have
it
yeah it's very common and you basically
just get the raw
data out from that wirelessly transmit
it to some sort of a
base station on the drone that is able
to convert
that data into actionable
motions for two different motors so they
can go left and right up and down
we don't need the twist that doesn't
sound that hard in theory it's not that
hard i just have no programming
experience to actually make it happen
yeah all of the other things like
actually like powering up all this stuff
3d printing mounts and building it i can
do that
now the guy that you know that can do it
i don't want to mention that i'm not
going to
i'm just saying he definitely has done
it before yes he's done something very i
know
before i haven't heard back from him yet
yeah i texted him he's super cool
um but i texted two guys they're both
very capable so you're gonna need a
helmet
made out of phones with gyrometers made
100 out of phones made 100 out of phones
we'll have to harvest them and all the
gyrometers will be synced
that'll that'll be the iml
and then that'll send the data mechanism
jake's the guest
[Laughter]
i mean i mean in theory i mean yeah i
don't know if we can actually figure
that out that'd be a pretty big deal for
like fpv in general because it's like
being able to actually have head
tracking
while you're flying because you'd also
want to include some sort of
uh like these sticks that go out just so
that you have some sort of
indication for where the camera is sure
uh in relation to the drone because
otherwise you'd think you're maybe
looking forward but actually looking up
and that changes everything with when
flying hpv it
yeah it's it'd be kind of a hard thing
but i'm hoping
is that it introduces a bit of like a
fighter pilot feel to flying drones
because it already it already feels like
you're locked into the cockpit of a
fighter
uh fighter jet right but being able to
actually be like all right
there's someone on my six oh that's that
would be something that'd be pretty
sweet
it's one step closer to the the thing
that everyone's always asking me about
online like when are they gonna have
like 360 cameras
be able to uh be the fpv feed and the
short answer is quite a while because
that's a lot of data
but if you can actually move the camera
that essentially
is the same sort of end result kind of
have you seen that video that guy
riding around on that drone uh like it's
a
jet board hunter kowald and i have been
chatting for a couple months now
okay because we were hoping to maybe do
a video together but then i broke my
collarbone
and that was all put on on hold and
pretty much right in that same week
he had a video just explode on tick tock
he went from like a few thousand
uh followers on instagram to like 150
more i don't know
um so was that legal what he was doing
so i was
flying around on a i was talking with a
friend of mine
yeah who um i mean basically
it seems to be slightly outside of the
uh faa rules and regulations for
for drone flying because it's now
carrying a passenger
so it now goes into the rules of like
ultra lights
and it's a different classification of
rules that i'm not familiar with
they hand those off to those complaints
go to spider-man i think yeah
like yeah yeah i want to do that so
badly
dude that yeah that'd be sweet who
doesn't man that looks like what is most
fun
whatever you did you built your thing
now
then you build another thing that can
fly you and then while you're on that
it's just you with a nerf gun someone's
flying that's the nerf drone 3.0 just
like that
nerf gun that's your [ __ ] final form
and then there's drones that you're
controlling while you're flying that are
flying next to you
while someone's flying your drone like a
swarm
it's a swarm of attack drones red is
gonna be a spider-man villain
it's like that's i mean hunter's drone
that he flies
it's like he's not the first one to come
up with that design there's been a few
different people who have
come up with very similar designs it's
basically just making
a big enough drone that can can carry a
couple hundred pounds
right and it's like you throw enough
batteries at it and big enough motors
enough motors big enough propellers at
it and it can do it
and i think he actually flies it with a
special made controller
meant for like rc cars uh it's not like
balance based as much
i think he i mean it's a combination you
can't just hit forward and not lean into
it
otherwise you'll fall out of the air you
should get him on the podcast
yeah the future future yeah we should
get him on the futurology futurologizing
yeah whatever yeah no his stuff is
really cool um
yeah sweet well that sounds like it's
gonna be a lot longer in development
this nerf drone 2.0 video yeah it's a
bit of a
and then oh can you get a tiny one can
you make a tiny attack drone to attack
mark rovers squirrels when they try to
get
his his uh walnuts
i don't know if you guys saw that that's
what we all want to know but that video
mark robert man i'm just going to talk
about every single one of his videos is
absolutely he has the youtube
algorithm in a vice grip he does yeah
it's like i first of all that video had
been popping up on my feed
for weeks and so i was it was late one
night and i was just wrapping up some
work and
i turned it on and i was just checking
emails and my kids were in
the back of my office and they
immediately saw it
and came over and then they sat on they
didn't even ask they just like got up on
me and they sat there
and they immediately started watching it
and it's like not only does he ha he's
got the four quadrants right he's got
like young
old male female he's got like
interesting proposition
work that went into it it's it's not
you know risque but it's also very
entertaining
and it's like yeah man mark's got a
formula
got it in a format down that is
something to behold and it's so much
more subtle than i think people realize
uh you know he always like he begins
every video by kind of outlining what
the video is gonna be but he does it in
a
very quick and entertaining way it
doesn't make you feel like you're
reading the introduction to an essay
right um he knows the sort of things to
gloss over that are actually like
for for nerds would be like super cool
to go into detail like his builds and
stuff he kind of just like glosses
through all the builds
uh in the engineering side of things
because he understands most people
aren't really going to care about the
engineering side of things
but they are going to care about why
certain aspects of the engineering are
special
right and and then it's all about just
delivering on you know
promises and we've got to do that video
with him yeah
that's such a good idea um and he was he
was down to do it with us
we should come back to it now so it's
it's basically uh ren and mark
invent a bike theft deterrent device
where there's a jet pack inside of the
post for the seat of the bicycle
street and anytime the non-owner sits on
the bike
the biker seat shoots up into the air
now it's important to clarify this was
going to be a parody
yeah this is going to be a video on our
channel that was basically uh
parodying the mark robert style but like
just taken to 11
like like and and mark was actually like
really interested in the idea of just
like
like just i get to be me but just like
crazy yeah
now that the pandemic's you know coming
to close and
and like i i really think we should pick
that back up again dude those like pogo
stick vfx or just shoot
requires well the reason why we stopped
cranes yeah the reason why we didn't
pursue that video is because it was
going to be too expensive because we
wanted to be able to do it with like
some real stunts and whatnot but it was
going to be
just far too expensive but i think
either if we get a
sponsor or if we get if we get it
greenlit
we could do it because it'll probably
cost about 20 grand
at least dude yeah that falls into that
perfect viral like
youtube thing like boss town dynamics
where you just like
make a fake viral video yeah but it goes
super viral because people think it's
real
well and then mark will be in it and yes
i think it'll work really well
granted last time we were pursuing this
was literally over two years ago is
before we ever did boss town it was one
of those videos we're trying to right
around that time
it was right around yeah what was before
it was like march and april
we did the first boss town and then we
realized hey there's a format here
in a there's a corridor format here
in making parody videos that are over
the top of what other things are popular
on youtube
and that's still a very viable format i
think for that channel
like you you yeah and what that that
video is a good example the boss town
dynamics
video is a good example um that's kind
of the
idea there we do a mukbang video where
the crabs fight back
and they end up mukbanging the humans
yeah there's eating those weird stuff
but you know those questionably moral
weird eating videos just the older
reality we'll eat
yeah that's the ultimate reality they're
gonna think that's gonna be my kind of
thing
who doesn't like a good mukbang come on
you know um this is a very particular
audience yes
strange strange world yeah there's so
many things on youtube that i just
like do they know this is on here did
anyone tell them
why are these videos here why are they
monetized and why is there a whole
section of content
that is this i know one of my favorite
mark robert videos
was it was from a few years ago
he was doing this whole video about like
this giant battery for a car and they
made a whole like lemon wall of
batteries
like where you plug in enough wires into
the lemons you can actually kind of
power
a small motor that was like the first
video i ever saw of his really yeah
uh well in this video it was a good
video but it was like a long 20 minute
video
inside of this video was like this
two-minute segment talking about
uh energy generation i think
and like being able to uh harness energy
but he did it in the form of making a
pat an electric zip line
oh well he literally like basically
attached a boosted board motor
to a zip line so you can go down the zip
line and generate electricity as you're
going down and when you get off it
automatically goes back up to the top
oh sweet and i just remember thinking
that was the coolest thing and it was
almost a throwaway moment in the video i
was like
come on man that was so cool we could
have easily made an entire video just
about that one little thing
yeah and he just like it was like oh
yeah by the way it was like by the way
it's just one way i mean maybe that
maybe that could be a video we do is
like make our own
motorized zip line and that's part of
the premise is that like you know mark
is it does the line it's does the device
that hangs onto the line
go go up or can it go up with you on it
i don't think it can go up with you on
it
okay i think that would be the epitome
of that yeah i don't i don't think it
had enough power to do that okay
takes you back up right so you can just
just hook your feet up along the top
jumper is infinite dude i mean that
could be the twist that we could do to
that i mean because i remember thinking
i was like i really want to do that i
really want to make that electric zip
line
but you know mark did it that would be a
twist i think he had someone else
working on it someone else actually like
designed and built it and he just
incorporated it in
um yeah because mark always has like a
team of people helping him with the
engineering and projects and stuff yeah
those videos are not cheap for him
no they're very complex and they acquire
a lot of people so
again on the bike theft deterrent video
yeah
probably 20 30 000 is probably what it
would cost but man
again it's it's one of those videos you
kind of got to do i feel like
i haven't thought about that idea since
we stopped thinking about it two years
ago
let's go yeah we should yeah let's do it
there's no
complications with location though that
was the thing there's like
we're gonna have to like rent out like a
whole plaza parking lot or something
like that in order to do it we probably
will but i think at this point if you're
talking about
you know 20 30 000 budget i mean you'd
have the money for it
to do that suppose yeah uh that that and
also like mark has gotten so much more
popular in the last two years he was
already super mega popular and now he's
just
top of the game yeah maybe we're too
little for him
i don't think that's how he thinks and
yeah
he's not a i know he's not a clout guy
he's not
he's he's one of the smartest guys i
know
yeah so yeah
um that's what's going on around here
any other fun corridor videos being
drummed up
my main channel yes we have uh we have
local zero that's you know basically
we're gonna finish
we're gonna finish son of a dungeon and
then local zero is gonna go
gonna go that's that video is all
pre-production though
because once you actually capture your
footage
you just edit it and add sound design
right pre-production until it's done
yeah basically basically yeah wow
yeah um so that's i really want to make
my moon video
what's your moon video what i want to go
to the moon
we got budget for the moon don't we got
some moon budget
no i just i remember reading this really
fascinating story and it's been a long
enough time now that i don't remember
the details but basically their intent
was to
turn a crater on the dark side of the
moon the far side of the moon
into a giant satellite dish by
laying a mesh of wires across it just
enough wire
and we're talking like a crater that's
like two kilometers wide like
huge any way bigger than anything we can
build on earth on top of that
it is using the entire moon itself to
exclude its
uh all of the radio waves from earth oh
my god so it'd be
completely clean radio waves that it'd
be um
seeing and be able to use that to like
look deep into space and whatnot if the
aliens are missing who's trying to do
that
oh yeah jpl i think more specifically
but i don't think it's an actual real
mission yet
finally put that thing to good use am i
right i mean that moon i know there's no
cheese there
come on it's not made out of cheese
everyone knows that now so
yeah i want to use that as a
to dig down and see how much cheese i
can find
i'm a cheese man oh cheese man my name
is
oh my gosh i want to use that as an
excuse to talk about all like the cool
like
fun facts about the moon that could be
in a video uh and literally
film it on the moon sorry let me
rephrase not literally filming on the
moon
i would be on the moon so we'd do it on
the green screen with virtual production
okay okay
would be the idea yeah and then nico's
itching to do another
narrative piece as we get into the fall
here so i imagine he's gonna
start writing that when he gets back and
we'll put that into development
we talked about doing gopro on a ghost
last year
oh yeah yeah yeah no you're a ghost
no it was like someone dies and it's
like a gopro kind of like
floats up it was it was when we had the
whole 360 camera
uh drone build that we did last year
where you could look anywhere
so it was like instead of like you know
go piranha on superman or superman with
a gopro it's like
a ghost with a gopro that would be
really funny to like shoot some
paranormal activity style
like you know setups but it's from the
perspective of the ghosts so it's
like yeah it's not scary anymore it's
like
i'm not really going anywhere but the
idea of
it's scary from the other way around
yeah yeah the only reason why they're
haunting people is because they're
freaking terrified of us
they're making noises because they keep
running away from us like banging
against
like them year we like we had this drone
and it was kind of on the janky side
like you'd crash and you have to like
replace the entire lens
and but like the potential for really
cool ideas was definitely there i don't
think i
even came close to maximizing the sort
of like ideas you could do
because of the limits of what i had
built but insta360 sorry
newbie drone has a new drone that
basically the entirety of it is thinner
than the insta 360
1r camera and so you literally just take
the camera you put it in the drone and
the drone is
gone and it flies pretty well i've had
some problems with mine i've i i broke
the power board for it
um but like it you have like these
little screen protectors that
clamp right on and they're plastic and
they're easy to replace
so i have like a couple dozen of them
and uh
it'd be really cool to film something
with it don't know what the right idea
is yet though that's the problem
go pro on a ghost yeah we're gonna have
it like phasing through buildings and
stuff yeah
like it could be cool yeah cool yeah
um and then one more thing that i want
to just mention
uh so i was digging into some copyright
claims
oh boy
the age-old age-old fiesta graham warned
us about this he said make sure you stay
on top of those copyright claims because
if you let them be then they'll get
worse
uh-oh how many do we have oh fester
do you want to know the truth yeah one
another give it to us straight jake
35. wait seriously what wait 35
different copyright claims
yes that are okay hold up
does copyright claim mean someone has
claimed a portion of the video and are
monetizing the whole video and we're
like ah screw it whatever fine
fine or is it like they're just in limbo
it's a status claim that is just there
and what you said first okay but some of
those are because of music tracks that
we used to use back in the day on the og
vlog that are
legitimately we either
now can't use or there was complications
with some of the
music white listing that we had with one
of the artists which is why we moved to
epidemic
anyway that's not really important the
main thing is that
these little ones where it's background
tracks
in in react episodes
and then the music publisher claims the
entire video because there's
a background track i'm and now i'm at a
point
so there's the way that this works in
youtube is there's a claim
and then you can dispute the claim and
then they can
say we don't we either feel your dispute
is valid or not
and then if they say that then you have
to appeal it and then
if and then they have another 30 days to
decide and then after after
that 30 days they say no it's still not
valid then they'll then they can choose
to have it taken down
or monetized for them and the only way
to get it back if it's either taken down
or monetized for them
is to then submit an actual um
lawsuit against them um so
i was talking with daniel about this
because we might have to do like an
actual lawsuit lawsuit on it and and
sort of pick we
obviously got to pick your battle um can
you do multiple claims
at once if it's the same company
claiming it uh
no because it's each
thing is dependent on the facts itself
the way that the fair use doctrine works
is it's not a
it's not a right it's a defense what's
that
oh that was no so the the thing is is
that
fair use isn't a right it's a defense
meaning that you can't like
claim it first you have to you have to
say it as like oh no i did it
i know i did that but i did it and it's
okay is how that works so
yeah so we've got 35 of these little
little buggers that that i'm going to
have to try to deal with tomorrow
and um and then we'll see what happens
but
are they mostly react like i know you
said some of them are old vlogs but like
those ones bug me because it's like we
got permission and it was all totally
fine and it's like
or in a lot of cases we would actually
get music from a stock music website
that was like free to use
oh yeah we're not free to eat whatever
like you were allowed to use them you
had the license to use them
and then like a couple years goes by and
like the ownership of that
license changes and they're like oh now
we don't can't use it it's like what
the the world of music publishing is is
messy
it's the main reason why we've never
done a music video episode of visual
effects reactions but
if you're subscribed to
corridordigital.com we are actually
talking on monday about doing
music videos and love death
death yeah more mature more mature yeah
rated r
type stuff that we can't really do on
youtube
um so more on that next week
but yeah um that i think people would
really enjoy that
oh for sure i hope so because people
have been requesting us to
to do music videos for a long time maybe
in like an upcoming vfx arts react we
can actually do like a comment push for
music videos yeah specifically for the
website because obviously we wouldn't be
able to do it on youtube did you
have you guys seen the website and we we
added those little uh
previews now oh yeah all the videos so
if when you scroll over the videos it
gives you a preview
oh i haven't seen that oh yeah it's
pretty sweet is it like a scrub style
type deal or you hover over it it just
like plays like a few images yeah
those are useful i like them um without
going into too much detail have we found
out any more information
about uh a week or two ago's react video
yeah
people have been asking me where'd it go
why is it offline yeah so
um you may have noticed vfx artist react
45 with godzilla v king kong
is currently not live wait not that one
well there's that one that one
not that one that one got claimed then i
thought we got it oh you're right sorry
i'm i've i've been looking at 35 of
these today i apologize it's the one
where we
uh we had felix on the guest on the
couch
we talked with ian about his
dynamo film yeah and ian yep so that one
um some people who i will not mention at
this time saw some footage and
i think they're very sensitive about
the success of the show and also
how it could possibly be construed that
so and so created something and
and actually such and such actually
created it and
you know they're very particular so they
asked us
to private it well they can get back to
us with
what exactly that is so when we can
clean it up and
and re and and re make republish it
um so but we haven't heard back well i
told them
i told them they have until friday at
noon and if we don't hear anything then
i'm gonna
just publish it again i press publish
yeah
watch the world
you've got the kill switch gonna think
there's a reason why i did that that
sounds harsh but the reason why is
because if you just say yeah
okay then they'll just go okay
they said they'd take it down until we
got back to him let's just never get
back to him
let's just never it's we got what we
wanted right you know and the world is
that's just how the world is you know
like people
especially when it comes to like these
types of players
they just they don't care they just want
what they want and
um so you know you just have to con you
have to make sure that anytime you're in
that situation you have something to
fall back on so that there's pressure so
that they
uphold their end of the bargain because
it's like you know everyone involved we
don't we don't want to like step on
anyone's toes we're trying to be
accomplished
we're trying to show like the best
possible portrayals of this stuff and
even when it's
bad cgi still talk about okay what were
they up against
what why did it go that way you know
what
what went wrong and do it not it's not
just a bash fest
even when it's not good cgi
um and we've always tried to uphold that
and i think that's what people enjoy
about is it's honest but it's also not
just
a haters take on a bunch of people who
put in a bunch of hard work on something
that's where it gets harder though
having
these like high-level industry vfx
artists on that now they're so
guess because like us we're just wildly
youtubers you know
we don't care about new rules but like
if you have
people from the industry on then they're
working on big ips owned by big
corporations and right and corporations
love their egos
well i mean it's also more than that
like when we had matt aitken on uh the
vfx supervisor from weta digital
we started trying to look at another uh
a comparison shot and he goes like hey
pull up this
this like other show this other movie as
an example and he got he got real
awkward real quick because he he was
like i i don't i don't feel comfortable
talking about anyone else a little like
red like freaking laser pointer
just like appeared and it totally makes
sense because it's like you know he's an
industry expert
he's he he talks he knows all
the people who work at all these other
companies and he doesn't want to
blast their work and i totally get it
you know it's like right
yeah but it's hard to have an unbiased
review of bad and good cgi
when uh but no that episode was awesome
no
everything we did with matt was amazing
those two episodes we got were
so good so good yeah and it was so cool
to have somebody with that much
intel yeah those are some of my
favorites honestly yeah
yeah those two episodes are great
speaking of bashing so we bashed scott
adkins the uh
the fight star yes the british fighter
and a man himself we're going to come on
and i think it would be fun to give him
some of our fight scenes
to maybe bash back a little bit yeah
oh my god that might be a fun thing
because he does have a great sense
of humor about it you know yeah um so
give some context on who he is real
quick because
eric yeah talked about him first in like
some uh i forget the movie it was like
it's like a rome type deal right he was
like a gladiator it's like some
who knows when it was trying to be in
history but like yeah we looked at this
fight scene with eric
uh lyndon in like one of our first
episodes i think
it wasn't that early it wasn't one of
the first episodes of stuntmen react
gotcha well yeah i looked at a couple
and you know scott atkins like he's
dude i was just watching a bunch of his
scenes today just doing some research
and like
dude's a crazy fighter like his kicks
are next level
like his kicks are crazy spins and stuff
but like
who can you hire him he gets cast in a
lot of he's made a really good career on
like he's kind of like
b grade for the lack of a better term
like movies that do like super well
overseas
and stuff like right now and stuff and
um
like and it's not like full hollywood
budgets but for that reason they come
off as cheesy sometimes to us
so they're easy to like you can also get
away with some of the stuff that we were
just
talking about not having to worry about
that you know and not having to worry
about like oh who's gonna see it and how
are they gonna feel
it's like no they can get down with
their
piece that they're creating and that's
what makes him cool
so you're saying he's coming on the show
he's coming on the show on yeah
tuesday we hope well unless like kovid's
stuff
over in england stops it but he's like
scheduled oh wow no that's that
okay the uk did just extend their
coveted protocols like today
that's why christian was just emailing
today to follow up on that
like he might not be actually allowed to
fly
there yes he's going to yeah it with me
yes all right
look at that news in real time
well should we bring maybe gion
nico yeah
all right so we're going to look at we
should re-look at the scenes that maybe
we
were like bashing yeah we should and
then yeah but dude he has some awesome
like truth like truthfully epic fight
scenes
that we got to look at nice it'll be
cool
sweet anyway lots of stuff to look
forward to
jake's breaking out the guitar you know
what that means tiny guitar he's going
to have a tiny guitar for it he'll be
sorry for the tiniest outro you've ever
heard in your life
is that like a child's guitar
[Music]
when you're on the corridor cast you
gonna have a blast welcome to the jks
guys you get it all here you get the
jank you get the insights
you get the real time you get the
futurology you get sam
or is it future futurology baby that's a
new religion called futurology
thanks for joining us once again and uh
we'll see you next week
right back here